welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer victims were
injured at the iwaka show Christmas
parade begin to testify in the trial of
Daryl Brooks Brooks is representing
himself as he stands trial for killing
six people and injuring dozens more law
and crimes Angela Levy has the testimony
from Wisconsin
she was lying in the middle of the road
and there were some people around her
trying to help her Kelly grobo recalled
seeing her daughter Adelia laying in the
street after being hit by the red SUV
Adelia had been handing out candy grabo
described hearing a different sound
behind them before they were hit I
noticed there's a difference in the
sound behind us than what I was hearing
throughout so right as she walked off to
the side and I seen she walked to the
side I turned I don't know if I turned
fully or just my head
and as I turned all I seen was the hood
of a red vehicle and I hit the red
vehicle and rolled down to the side and
landed directly between the Burris
Logistics Daryl Brooks cross-examines
each witness that he is charged with
injuring he has declared himself a third
party intervener as he represents
himself do you recall seeing a driver
no I've seen the red hood of the vehicle
that's all I've seen
so you didn't see the driver anybody in
the vehicle no Brooks's questions appear
to suggest he can't be identified as the
driver by some witnesses he's also asked
many people whether or not they heard a
horn so when he looked back you said you
heard screaming you heard yelling and
running
did you hear a horn honking I did not
Joshua Crainer testified to being hit by
the SUV I was struck by the vehicle
where did the vehicle strike you
I don't remember
okay did you receive any injuries as a
result of the vehicle striking you yes
and what were those injuries
[Music]
I couldn't walk Brooks has tried to
raise doubts through his
cross-examinations about who was driving
the red SUV so it would be fair to say
that at no time during the incident
you saw the driver
no I did not Daryl Brooks has declared
himself a sovereign Citizen and he wants
the case against him dismissed saying
the court does not have jurisdiction but
Judge Jennifer Doro has denied that
request in Waukesha Wisconsin I'm
Anjanette Levy for Law and crime daily
thanks Anjanette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney Taylor Koss
and co-host Terry Austin Taylor Brooks
keeps asking and the judge keeps
shutting him down but is there a
plaintiff in this case and does it
matter
uh thanks for having me guys a pleasure
to be here so typically speaking in a
criminal matter are the parties are
going to be the prosecution and the
defendant uh the state versus the
defendant the government versus the
defendant you very rarely have ever hear
uh that there's a plaintiff that that is
just not a term used in criminal law
however uh earlier in one of the
pre-trial proceedings the judge actually
said on the record uh when talking to
the defendant do you understand that the
state of Wisconsin is the plaintiff in
this matter and that stuck in his head
and he's glommed on to that now because
as you know we've all known he is
claiming he's a sovereign citizen of the
United States that while the U.S
Constitution applies to him the
Wisconsin Constitution does not apply to
him so he keeps trying to associate the
state of Wisconsin with being the
plaintiff
um for future jurisdiction arguments it
has absolutely no merit
um but that's why he's doing it and he's
trying everything uh it's cuckoo but
it's what's going on yeah a lot of Cocoa
Puffs in there has you said cuckoo well
Terry there are times that Brooks
actually seems prepared do you think
he's getting some sort of legal advice
from somewhere or someone oh I
definitely think he's getting some
jailhouse advice while he is behind bars
he's also watching the prosecution he's
learned some of the phrases and some of
the key behaviors of the prosecution
like when he objects I've noticed a
couple of phrases like he was prepared
for it whenever the state objects he
always says what grounds and he doesn't
even give the prosecutor an opportunity
to finish her sentence I think someone
told him you have the right to say what
grounds are you objecting on and if you
notice he's also using certain phrases
so he says is it fair to say and he's
saying let me just clarify for the
record these are things that he's heard
people talking about yeah grounds
grounds grounds he's trying to build
some sort of an appeal we'll see what he
does as the kids continues well still
ahead on Law and crime daily we continue
our coverage of the Waukesha parade
crash Massacre a parade crash witness
breaks down on the stand why the
defendant is later called out for his
commentary
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage in
the trial of Wisconsin versus Daryl
Brooks on Tuesday prosecutors call for
Brooks to stop making comments under his
breath after a witness became emotional
on the stand
and we can take that down now thank you
so miss kojewski as well let me just
clarify
what did we see at the end of that video
through the parade
we took the videos the resin is
irrelevant
sir dear it's not a objection
s
later
go ahead so judge before we begin I have
to step in here and request that Mr
Brooks be instructed to stop making
comments under his breath this witness
is very clearly having an emotional and
difficult time testifying and she
doesn't need to hear that
Jason she can't hear anything I'm saying
Mr Brooks the mics are very good in this
courtroom so please refrain
Terry these victims have the patience of
the Saints as they're being
cross-examined by Brooks especially when
they're asked if they ID the driver
after a loved one was hurt how do you
think the jury is reacting to that oh
you know that jury is looking at him as
though he's arrogant and condescending
because you know why he is arrogant and
condescending he is really being very
difficult and it's going to hurt his
case I definitely think that he's been
rude to all of the witnesses the
officers who were on before the family
and victims came on and his
ex-girlfriend he needs to be respectful
as the Dutch has said many times to
everyone in that courtroom and when you
have a witness who's been injured or
whose family member has been injured you
especially have to show deference that
jury is looking at him and they will
absolutely hold it against him even if
they felt sorry for him because he
doesn't know his way around the
courtroom it's definitely going to hurt
him yeah I don't think a lot of sympathy
is going Brook's way but Taylor from
what Brooks is asking can you take an
educated guess as to what his summation
would look like and will it help with
any of these charges
well first of all I think it's fair to
say that the summation is going to be uh
as close to a three-ring circus as
humanly possible but you know what what
you know if we can hone in on something
the Common Thread from what I've seen
and what he's trying to get from the
witnesses during his cross-examination
is that they didn't see him driving the
car they can't describe him they can't
describe features of him driving the car
at least some of the witnesses
um so so it's fair to assume he's going
to argue some sort of identification
issues additionally he's brought up this
issue of did you hear a honking horn did
you hear a honking horn perhaps uh if uh
identification is acknowledged perhaps
he's going to say you know he tried to
notify people there was a honking horn
everybody should have known to get out
of the way either way don't think he's
going to be successful on any of these
um the identification uh particularly
but you know the fact that they didn't
see him so to speak driving the car
something he's gotten his hooks into and
likely to repeat on end uh during his
summation yeah we'll see how it plays
out I'm curious I don't know the answer
on the top of my head but we'll answer
it another day can he be both are all
three defendant witness and and uh
lawyer maybe he'll take the stand
himself well we'll see how that plays
out another ring to that circus you were
talking about well switching now to
another highly publicized case as a
non-side is officially exonerated in the
murder of Heyman Lee prosecutors in
Maryland dropped all charges on Tuesday
syed's case Rose to Fame in 2014 when
the podcast serial broke listening
records They investigated a series cast
doubt on sale's 2000 conviction for the
murder of his ex-girlfriend 18 year old
Hayman Lee since he was arrested back in
1999 Syed has maintained his innocence
he spent more than 20 years behind bars
in September a Maryland judge ruled to
vacate Zion's conviction seeing State
evidence in the original investigation
wasn't handed over to the defense and
that two murder suspects were cleared
that should not have been say it has
then been was then released the
prosecution was then given 30 days to
decide whether to retry Sayed or drop
the charges on Tuesday prosecutors
announced DNA evidence excluded Syed as
a suspect
coming up on Law and crime daily after
weeks of testimony closing arguments are
presented and the Parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial plus why the
Church of Scientology is in the
spotlight as actor Danny Masterson faces
charges of rape in California